thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a tactical
wild ride with Stevo we're going for
anti-terrorism this week with a
decorated military hero a sniper guy
who's very candid about having deaded a
bunch of people that's right it's Tim
Kennedy you don't get more candid I mean
the guy invited Al-Qaeda Isis like to
come try to kill him at his house and
announced his home address on Fox News
That's how crazy this guy is and man I
feel good about this episode I feel good
in general because I'm sitting here
pushing 50 years old and straight
kicking butt on my skateboard now how's
that even possible well for starters I
take care of myself and my diet I plug
in the gaps in my diet by using ag1 from
athletic greens now what is that it is
the most comprehensive convenient daily
nutrition that you can get it's loaded
with 75 different uh whole food sourced
superfoods vitamins minerals
adaptogens probiotics I mean it's all
loaded into this green powder which is
absolutely delicious I start my mornings
with it dump it into a pint of water to
hydrate myself and any gaps in my diet
are filled for the day plus it helps
with my gut health with my brain health
that's right and you can get a killer
deal if you go to athletic greens.com
Stevo what's the deal they're going to
give you five free comprehensive daily
nutrition travel packs plus an entire
year supply of immune boosting vitamin D
with your first order I mean I use it
all the time I love it I'm super healthy
and you should be too so get over to
athleticgreens.com
Devo for that killer deal with the five
travel packs the year supply of vitamin
D it's killer now let's get into it
they're just gonna bring out a couple
coffees
all right
I'm should we wait for that or no let's
go all right you're in Texas coffee yeah
this is just it it's part of life here
we go
ladies and gentlemen Tim Kennedy I went
like Rambo music to play when somebody
says my name yeah dude but then they
actually meet me like uh so
underwhelming that
that makes perfect sense that you should
have Rambo music you are like a real
life Rambo
um and you remember Scott Randolph
gorgeous as ever you know you you know
do you remember at the uh Paramount
Theater in Austin when we did the show
yeah post traumatic stress still from
that yeah and then I thought I killed
you well Steve before Steve walked out
on stage he was like
make sure he drops me on my head and
then he walks out and I went back and
told you and you're like all right and
so you see on the footage he dropped him
on his head I did but I mean I was like
is he dead is he dead and I've I've
deaded some people and I was I was
worried for a moment
yeah
that I feel like uh
man I feel like there is some situation
not with you
but with uh like some sort of person
who's in a military situation it's
basically not cool to ask someone about
killing people right generally it's kind
of weird but I always I also think that
people like oh man it's not cool to like
you know ask that it's because you've
never actually done none of it right you
know on the flip side dudes like that
you just met in that office we've been
at War for we were at War for 21 years
and uh everybody that you just met in
there was that was in the war for 20
some odd years and if you're a special
force a sniper or you're a seal or
you're in Delta Force and and you
haven't like debted some people like
maybe you're really bad at your job and
uh and if you're also like touchy about
talking about it maybe maybe there's
something wrong with you not the work
so you you processed it all yeah
afterwards in therapy
um well I mean in like in life I might
have an mm you processed it all in MMA
like I got a great family I got great
friends you know so like definitely
process definitely like talked and you
know I'm still in the business so like
like I just got back from overseas a
couple of days ago and went straight
into hunting and got back from hunting
those pictures I sent you as I was
driving back I'm so tired
um and yes you are active military as we
speak
and right now I'm on your awesome couch
in the school band this is a great van
yeah thanks man it's it's a fun gimmick
dude we uh we do very well bringing the
studio to the guests is this a yak that
is uh as fake as could be yeah yeah but
you know I
like that like
I I'm an outspoken animal guy I love
animals me too I super respect the
hunting I want to say that on the record
real hunting yeah yeah because there's
some people that do some wacko stuff
that's they're not real hunters and we
hate them and we eat them for lunch but
I really appreciate you saying that yeah
I mean like the like uh trophy hunting I
think is whack I don't respect that I
hate it uh you know but like hunting for
food it makes all the sense in the world
to me and um I I believe that it that it
should be like a custom of our society
that if you're going to eat meat you
have to become licensed to eat meat and
to get that license you should have to
kill an animal oh that's heavy
um I love this idea I uh I love people
having to experience with a degree of
responsibility
freedoms yeah you know uh
I I even though I'm like pretty anti-any
form of regulation in anything I'm like
a super Freedom First sovereignty like
um like total freedom I'll bake you a a
cake full of weed from my gay neighbor
you know like don't don't care do
whatever you want as long as I get to be
free
um you know but with that there has to
be a degree of individual responsibility
sure where somebody appreciates the
value of this Freedom you know and like
hunting is a perfect example of it where
do you understand the conservation side
of why we hunt where we hunt when we
hunt how the seasons work how we coal
herds how we make sure they're
genetically natural because we've we
have humans have messed up things the
natural ecosystems that you know the
Predators that would keep herds down to
a normal manageable like even deer to a
normal manageable population now they're
starving and they have diseases because
those Predators were eradicated because
we're humans and we're like locusts and
we just keep spreading so we have to
then
inject ourselves into these ecosystems
to make sure they stay healthy and like
um I want people to understand that but
they don't you know there's like oh just
you know punch my ticket all you know I
was like can you help me understand like
when somebody I know there's a couple
instances in in Africa where like you
know somebody goes giraffe hunting or
they kill a giraffe but that giraffe has
been causing problems on the village
they have to spend a lot of money to get
the license to Kill the giraffe and then
the vast majority of that money goes
back to the area where that animal came
from and preserving the little bits of
actual area where those animals could
naturally exist
so we'll use
um bear for example in New Mexico if you
want to get a bear tag in New Mexico and
you're going to go shoot a bear
um like a bear attack
permit license to kill a bear yeah
that's right they look at an area they
calculate the number of bear that live
in that area and then they then they
look at the amount of food that's
available in that area for that number
of bear
if there's enough food to keep 20 bear
alive healthy that the extra numbers of
bear are the numbers of tags that
they're going to generate let's say
there's 28 bear so you're gonna have
eight tags that are going to be
generated off of that area off of that
lot if they don't generate those tags
not some of those bear will die a lot of
those bear will die in a very unhealthy
way they'll come down in to find food in
garbage cans they'll get hit in the
street they'll starve to death they'll
have diseases
um but the general the money that's
generated off of the sale of those tags
goes back to pay for the lands that
those animals normally exist on so just
in this one tiny little example of one
we're doing great conservation of pain
for the land and paying for the actual
um environments what what Ducks the
Wetland preservation or New Mexico
Colorado Utah Montana Africa all of
those instances are like the money that
is generated directly goes back to these
communities or back to these places
these habitats that these things exist
and then we're also taking care of the
animals but that's good hunting then
there's like the [ __ ] that always
and there's always [ __ ] that give
everything a bad name you know posing
with some thing and there's like is that
it's embarrassing
the the [ __ ] are they universally
breaking the law being [ __ ] like are
the laws sort of structured to make
hunting good hunting or is there like
legal [ __ ] hunting no they're they're
you have to work to be a legal [ __ ]
Hunter okay
um or you have to be really rich okay
you mean like shooting uh animals from a
helicopter
what do you think about that it depends
on what you're like here in Texas we we
have you know javelina or the javelina
South Texas and Javelin is protected
before there's too many so that's okay
yeah boar is a totally different thing
Javelin is actually like a rat people
think they're pigs but they're not
they're like they're more like a muskrat
than they are a pig yeah it's weird but
the pigs here 10 years ago there there
was less than a hundred uh less than 100
anyways the population now 25 of all
agriculture in the state of Texas is
destroyed by feral pigs and the the they
the sows start having litters as I mean
they're they're less than a year old and
they can have two three litters a year
and they could have nine to 20 piglets
per litter so like these things are just
[ __ ] like pigs oh yeah I'm just like
babies everywhere you can blow it up you
can shoot them from helicopters you can
shoot them with machine guns you know
you can hunt them year round they're
non-indigenous so there's no permit
necessary and we did we like Dent the
population and we and we positively make
effect but
they're so invasive that they're killing
everything just like the Burmese pythons
in Florida they're not from there oh my
God Florida's got all kinds of invasive
[ __ ] with the the lizards yeah the
Iguana the iguanas killing everything
eating babies ducks eating babies yeah
they eat baby ducks oh are they baby
humans no no is it geese or ducks that
are that are little birds taking over
Florida invasive Ducks huh yeah those
things dude it's crazy yeah we mess
things up we bring things to where
they're not supposed to be there's no
natural Predators for those things to be
there and then they just like blow up so
then we have to
I mean like Covina
okay
um you've been to the island I'm not
familiar with Crow I thought you were
saying it West Coast sorry
um
Catalina and buffalo they do have
Buffalo yeah did they get did they were
they there no no no did we were there
pigs on Catalina no no but we Wrigley
brought them over we bought them over
there yeah and they started destroying
everything then they hired people like
me to come over and hunt them from
helicopters yeah you know so like there
are times where it's it's fine and
important like we've we've darted
Buffalo and and wolves you know when we
reduced wolves back into Yellowstone
um like we did it and have you ever seen
the documentary dude what what happened
to the also once they brought back walls
it was like the most incredible thing
Rivers started yeah um changing
direction because Beaver started coming
back and or the beaver population
started being controlled it was just
like I have the introduction of an
animal that should have been there but
then we messed it up and then they
killed him then they came back have you
seen that documentary it was like it's
like eight minutes on YouTube like what
happened to Yellowstone when the Wolves
came back I I'm not aware of that it's
amazing I got the chills just talking
about it they literally changed
directions of rivers by introducing an
animal that used to exist there but then
we messed it up and then we reintroduced
the answers it brought order to like the
whole seal so does that count as a
regenerative farming yeah yeah I think
so yeah
um I mean it's it's crazy I
um
that
um I can't be new in Texas thanks bro I
like this I'm stoked to be here
um I'm fascinated with like what I
perceive to be a very
vulnerable and and precarious Society
like increasingly so like the the the
the dollar like the the debt like the
American government seems to be such a
Ponzi scheme of just debt and and it's
also unsustainable and it's all around
the world and I feel like we're just at
the like the cusp of some imminent
gnarly collapse we just hit eight
billion people yesterday
sure yeah and and the 31 trillion
dollars in debt does not count unfunded
liabilities like Social Security and
Medicine House of Cards is built pretty
high right now the House of Cards is
built extremely high and I'm trying to
imagine in the case of the inevitable
collapse it's really just like a matter
of when like
does
does martial law become a thing and is
there like training going on in the
military
who do you work for
yeah I mean like uh like you hear crazy
theories like uh or or rumors of like
you know what do you call them like
prison camps that are like being built
for like this type of uh eventuality
yeah um I I believe like you that a
reset is coming
um I don't know well I think we got to
see how fractured and fragile Society it
is
um during covet and during the civil
unrest like the antifa BLM those things
were happening concurrently right
um or towards the end of Trump's
um presidency uh you know we saw cities
burning we saw
um riots we saw
um you know horrible things that you'd
never imagined happening in the United
States happening and
most most experts think that three meals
people missing three consecutive meals
is how much it takes for Anarchy and
chaos to really come over you know and
take over where neighbors are doing
gross things to neighbors to try and put
food on their table you know if you
remember it was it was only two years
ago that there were food lines out in
front of supermarkets where you would
have to wait your turn to go back in to
get the allocated amount of food during
covid that you were allowed to get you
know like
only two things of toilet paper
ah everybody remembers the days of
brawls going down in supermarkets over
rolls of toilet paper because everybody
loves to take a good mean dump now this
episode is of course comes out on
Thanksgiving you know the day after
Thanksgiving it's called Brown Friday
you know why it's called Brown Friday
because it's the Plumber's most busy day
of the year because people are taking
huge dumps of that big Thanksgiving meal
and I'll tell you when you take a dump
you want to take a complete dump and in
order to do that you need Squatty Potty
it's a killer little stool that fits
around the base of your toilet by
putting your feet on it while you take a
dump you put your body into a crouching
position which it was intended by Mother
Nature to be in for dumps I mean mother
nature didn't have toilets that we sit
on on we're in the wrong position to be
taking a dump when we're sitting on the
toilet and I firmly believed in this
product since years before I ever got
into business with this company I've
been using Squatty Potty for
almost an entire decade and I feel so
good about it man it just helps you take
a more complete dump it keeps you
healthier and I mean not using Squatty
Potty I think is a health risk so get
one of these cool squatty potties for
your toilet and get 20 off your order by
going to
squattypotty.com
Stevo again that's 20 off your order at
squattypotty.com slash Stevo now let's
talk a little bit more about those
pandemic restrictions
for only two gallons of water only one
thing of oatmeal you know you could take
no more than
um four pounds here in Texas like they
had very strict this is like what you're
allowed to do
um we also had us we think we called it
snow apocalypse here we had a cold front
come in and it was like two weeks of
snow
the state is built was that when Ted
Cruz went down the Cancun that's the one
yeah yeah that's and so so because of
the the cold front came in and the
electrical power grid could not
withstand the the heating yep phase
blackouts and uh
while covet is happening while people
are still like freaking out and rioting
um it people were freaking scared you
know and um
everything's still fine
nothing actually had gone wrong yet
right and so we are
very very very in a precarious place of
truly things going bad right so uh yes
people are doing training
um we do training that's we have tons of
we have provider courses protector
courses
um you know situation awareness courses
that are all civilian facing and then we
have a military law enforcement Wing
where we train departments on how to
respond and react to a lot of those
things and then on like the national
level there are total X they're
absolutely exercises that are going on
um training around this stuff if there
is an apocalypse or a reset what are
like the top three things that you're
glad you have you have you want a
generator you want a food supply and you
want a gun those are good anything else
in water I mean like if we went down
this prepper because I'm like prepper
I'm prepper no yeah no [ __ ] yeah
um
try a community family friends it's
um it's really easy like I got my gold
bag I got my gun you know I got my water
purifier fire you know I have a
generator you know and cool that stuff's
Gonna Last like a week when it really
comes to
longevity it takes it takes a community
you know it takes trusted allies
um like if you think Hunger Games like
it you really have to have a group a
connected group that are that had share
that have shared values that have shared
vision and we'll be able to collectively
fight and stay together can share food
so obviously as a hunter with my mini
freezers that have redundant power
sources
um I'm gonna have that's a redundant
power source it just keeps it will never
run out of whatever but that's what just
keeps going on I don't know how the
engineering is behind that but it's
really easy engineering it is it's not
it's not hard so like
um if the pal it's the power grid
crashes right okay there is one form of
initial energy like power battery
systems that are powered by solar but
let's say you're in the middle so
apocalypse and there's not enough sun to
charge the batteries that keep the life
supporting things going then we also
have generator like whole house
generators that run off propane and
Diesel and then you have some that are
on natural gas so when I say redundant I
mean redundant
um so like I will have enough meat
forever and um yeah but like I need
veggies and I need fruits but I'm not
really a farmer so back to the community
and tribe I have tons of friends in my
like click to trade that will trade yeah
that will like barter and be like cool
here's an elk backstrap can I have you
know some artichokes and some zucchini
it'd be great yeah so what
uh size of a of a community like this do
you think it takes oh 20 30 20 30. it
takes a village yeah yeah I mean yeah
prep prepping it's it's gnarly yeah
um but
people thought I was insane three years
ago
in 2019 that's right yeah and then
you know like
we're our courses are sold out for a
year and a half like I can't hire people
enough fast enough that are qualified
enough to train the number of people
that are asking all the things that I
was screaming from the rooftops three
and a half years ago you know like and
the and the reset hasn't even happened
yet like that was just a little taste of
like here's something that barely kills
anybody but gets you kind of kindly a
little bitty sick yeah
um I I think it's wild that uh
the the three years you know like three
years ago people weren't hip to this you
know like uh long you got into it a
little while ago I I got into it
in
2010
2011. what you read something or my dad
was telling me that the the dollar is
gonna collapse you know like buy gold
don't uh
you know don't don't buy a house because
uh you know like the house in America is
gonna be like a a
cabin on a sinking ship or something
like now I don't think that America my
dad would would have everybody believe
that America is in a much worse position
should the dollar collapse but I just
think that the whole world is so
joined at the hip it's like I have a
Canadian passport so like uh
you know I've thought about ah don't go
there
yeah that's not gonna be any better yeah
I don't think that I don't know that
it's good Trudeau is gonna going to give
you Freedom
yeah but but I I think about it a lot
just in general and um weird like the
writing was on the wall a long time
before covet and then like that we
really sped up the process with covet
with the money Printing and yeah and
then now with the the hiking up the
interest rates to try to combat the
inflation it feels like all we're
getting is stagflation now yeah right
meaning that like inflation's out of
control and nobody has any money yeah
yeah I
this Q4 of of 2022 retail wise I think
it's going to be a really great
indicator for people uh to recognize how
dangerous financially a lot of people
are there's a lot of debt that was
carried over from covid when people were
out of work or
um you know they're getting locked out
of their Apartments the property owner
couldn't kick them out yet right because
um they're frozen uh and they weren't
allowed to kick anyone out but that
property owner now has seven properties
and six of those people haven't paid so
like that property owner is now in
bankruptcy with the brand with the bank
like all of that's going to be cascading
yeah well you saw Amazon meta and Google
they're laying off tens of thousands of
people Twitter fired 3 000 like there's
like 35 000 jobs as of today done
yeah yeah right after midterms by the
way and gas just went down no gas just
went up what but it's like two bucks
here yeah you're in Texas yeah it's like
five or six in California yeah yeah um
you're intact that's all taxes that's
California taxes meanwhile the the price
of of oil is 88 bucks a barrel yeah it's
like the lowest it's bad it's not the
most it's been it was way lower in the
pandemic because nobody was driving
during the Trump era it was half what it
is right now four oh 40 yeah yeah that's
I mean typically like historically the
oil is about 100 bucks a barrel you know
so there's no [ __ ] reason why gas
should be so exciting no it's crazy this
is uh
are you in the are you with the theory
that uh oil is never ending and it's
always regenerating yeah and they just
have the the scarcity tactic of like
it's running out it's just always going
to regenerate itself yeah I mean it's
not like we're not all of the stuff that
that is in the center of the earth came
from the Earth English is always going
to be there yeah
um and and finding more of it and we're
getting better at finding it and right
with the fracking and the the Sands yeah
and you are in a very
energy rich state so when you start
talking oil and natural gas here in
Texas people are like you know they get
really it's a huge industry here and um
they they get angry you know with the
passionate passionate good word
um about how ignorant the rest of the
country is about it um
um the uh I mean the fact of of oil this
is Black Rifle coffee
it's really good I really like it
oh oil like the what America tastes like
oil consumes like two million barrels
more oil every day than than it produces
is that really so it's like a net
negative but we we can produce as much
as we want
but we don't because of the Keystone
Pipeline a variety of reasons um that
being one of them uh that where we're
allowed to drill where we're allowed to
have pipes
um but production and storage are
um federally controlled and that that
Ebbs that ebb and flow happens with
every Administration and right now it's
very constricted and then during the
Trump era it was it was very not even
very loose it was loose
um so it's like it's always currently
we're in a Delta where we're using
reserves or buying it from foreign but
we absolutely have the ability to be
totally energy independent
that would that would be good no like we
if we could do it like that and we're
energy independent you mean America just
relies on itself or whatever it needs
all the resources so all resources
that's voter problems
voter problems yeah why
the um talking points of like the green
New Deal or how what kind of energy
renew renewable energies we're supposed
to be having
um and all of that is the biggest scam
of that anybody with any understanding
of economics and math that looks at any
form of renewable energy and it's like
wait how's it takes how much
materials to make one wind turbine and
that wind turbine makes how much power
and that power is then stored in how
many lithium batteries and those lithium
battery batteries take how much material
so like the carbon of this compared to
the carbon
well that doesn't make sense okay we'll
move to another one let's go to solo
solar okay so to make a solar panel
we're going to find these materials and
we're going to buy it from this place
and then ship it from there to here
we're going to manufacture it in this
other country and then ship it from
there to here and then we're going to
make all of that energy and then we're
also going to need the batteries and to
buy those lithium we have to buy that
lithium it's only in a few different
places renewable energies it's a scam
okay it's a scam like go nuclear if you
really care or just realize that we have
enough energy with true and energy
Independence here I mean there is like
for all the people talking about how
great electric cars are yeah you're
running on coal brother like I love your
electric energy your electric vehicle I
have a Tesla yeah cool you charge you
charge it with coal or you could charge
it with any other fossil fuel
so my carbon footprint is actually not
doing pretty good since I know about a
Tesla no because I guess that once the
battery dies out they got to bury it and
never like you know even biodegrades
into the grounds is there forever
yeah I don't know I don't know how
lithium biodegrades
it's probably not pretty good no but
like
uh man there's amazing um Joe Rogan had
them on their podcast This brilliant
um
um she she perf or he wrote a book on
all he did was compare foreign
individual all forms for a human to live
of energy and the most efficient the
like the least amount of waste with the
least
um lowest amount of carbon was Nuclear
by this crazy margin I mean we're
talking like a couple of tablespoons but
and but there's a visual weapons
representation and on the far farthest
furthest end of the spectrum was
renewable energies like the amount of
crap for renewable energies and uh and
it becomes obsolete so fast and then
it's all trash and yeah it's a dude that
like spends lots of time in third world
countries and which are the second and
third markets for used renewable
energies so all the solar panels that
are on every house in America right now
that have their 20-year lifespan when
those get pulled off those get shipped
to Africa and they exist for another or
10 years and then you but they they try
to use them for five or ten years but
marginally effective then they just end
up in Africa you know it's like the it's
the garbage disposal for the rest of
First World countries kind of like uh
Michigan is the garbage disposal for
Canada
yeah and Canada pays Michigan to to
deliver or to take their trash really
yeah thank God
that's like I want to say Michigan's
biggest industry trash yeah that's sad
how many countries have you been due do
you know that number
[Music]
I have like eight or nine Stamped Out
passports
yeah because Steve and I like to keep
track I'm at 50. he's at 55 but I'm
wondering I think I'm at 58. he's like I
can only talk about the 50.
yeah I don't know I mean wait oh like on
Africa
I I was with my kids just a couple of
days ago I was pointing at like the one
or two countries I hadn't been to wow
you know and like the whole continent
and then in Europe
um I don't think
right I'm in Russia it's the only one
really you've never been to Russia huh
yeah I'm can't go there
you'll go to jail faster than Brittany
Granger
yeah
hey so this special forces dude just
landed in Moscow
Jason Jason Bourne just landed right man
could you imagine
right but that hasn't stopped you from
going to the Middle East
um so and yeah but he's like probably
camouflaged In the Heat of the Night
yeah dressing up like a tree for three
weeks coming through the airport with
his passion right he's not Argo again
you know going through trying to get
people out like that yeah that was the I
remember the last thing that really
you know like the TMZ and Tim Kennedy
and and he's like they're gonna
you know they're gonna come after him
the Isis oh yeah that was a while ago it
was it was it was a long time ago yeah
yeah the um
yeah Isis was here in Texas when I when
I when I first moved here they were like
actively recruiting for a couple years
to try and find an Isis radical
operative to find out where I lived to
attack me and my family
so the FBI shows up at my door well they
called me first and they're like hey uh
uh like we have credible information
that Isis is trying to recruit locally
somebody to come and kill you
can you imagine finding out that Isis is
trying trying to send someone to your
house to kill you let that sink in and
imagine how well you would sleep that
night well
now imagine that you're sleeping on a
mattress from Helix sleep.com sleeping
just got a lot easier why because when
you go to helixsleep.com you take this
fun super fast little quiz which matches
you up to the perfect mattress for you
and or your partner and boom you're set
up with the most comfortable most
effective Best Rest mattress that you
can get and if you go to Helix sleep.com
slash Stevo you get up to 200 off all
mattresses plus two free pillows when
you get one man oh by the way that is
only for the listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast man I love Helix I love their
mattresses I love their pillows and I
love you guys so let's all come together
and get that disgusting chairs out and
that killer perfect new mattress from
Helix sleep.com in so one more time for
up to two hundred dollars off of any
mattress plus two free pillows it's
Helix sleep.com slash Stevo now let's
talk about these guys trying to kill Tim
amazing it's like I've been waiting for
this seriously like I have to fly so
many terrible places to find these
people and you're telling me that
they're going to come to Texas like I
couldn't have been more ecstatic and um
and they're like I'm sorry you don't
understand I'm like no no you don't
understand it's fine everything's
fantastic and the guy's like okay we're
gonna come talk to you so whatever like
the field Chief the the station Chief
like the boss here came over with um one
of their agents and like you know hello
Mr Kennedy I was like yes this is great
fantastic they're like well please don't
do anything rash so I called my friends
at Fox News and I went on Fox News and I
told my ad address live on live
television because I think I live at
9500 Cedar Crest Drive Austin Texas you
know
um send whoever you want just know that
you're never going to get them back you
know like that's it and like I said that
live on television and uh my wife left
me
um for a moment really yeah she was so
mad at me I mean she's been around long
enough to know what she signed up for
like I had just gotten back from my rack
where we had killed the number two bad
dude on the planet yeah the number one
bad guy in the whole entire country is
our Cowie and um and she like married me
right after that so dude that's what
I've been dying to ask you is uh I know
you did you did something about being
tortured and like waterboarding just to
show like those are different things
what we said you did this thing about
being tortured and waterboarding but you
like
colluded those two yeah those are
different things yeah waterboarding is
not tortured yeah that's literally what
I was showing yeah waterborne because I
always wanted to film a video with Steve
like going through like different like
he would be bored if you waterboarded
him he'd be like
then why do people like cap out I'm
barely uncomfortable it uh it's kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it is it's not I'm not
gonna say that it wouldn't be
uncomfortable but I just don't think
it's visually like impressive or
shocking to it is uncomfortable yeah but
you were very familiar with this Comfort
yeah it's kind of like being it's like
jumping in the water and you don't play
yeah it is not a thing it um I mean I
was I was waterboarded I you know like
there's really strict guidelines as to
what you're allowed to do when you're
waterboarding
um in this this is the rules of engage
like the rules of what like War when you
capture somebody no so all forms of
enhanced interrogation and that's what
waterboarding was
um and they don't do it anymore so
there's there's a bunch of enhanced
interrogation techniques but techniques
there's a really clear Sops like this is
how you do it this is how it's safe to
do it so you don't drown own somebody or
hurt somebody and there's also useful
information so real information is
something that's dependable reliable and
usable if you're pulling somebody's
fingernails out and drilling their hands
you know does that enhanced
interrogation that is not that's torture
okay and there's no information there
because that person would say anything
to get out of this and to get out of
torture uh you know like my mom is a
goose the sky is purple you're right my
mom yeah my mom
whatever so that the that's the fine
balance of in enhanced irrigation
finding truth and but
goal is to put somebody under a really
serious external stressors that are
constant so that you can decipher truth
from fallacy
and if you don't have a
status if you don't have a baseline
there's no way that you'd ever be able
to gauge truthfulness from a lie what
about a lie detector test
um that doesn't always helpful
and when you are trying it's like yes no
questions lie detector tests and and you
know voice stress analyzers polygraphs
um those can be useful and when the
American Military and government does it
on us for our security clearances
um they're like yes nose like
um are you an agent for a for a foreign
entity
no you know do you have any business
relationships with Russian agents no
like really easy but we also have bass
lines where they know and that's that's
like developed over time so it's not in
the field or it's baselines meaning like
your Biometrics that they know who you
are and like he's always at a 70 for
some reason is that at 82 heartbeats per
minute like that's weird yeah that's
interesting and in like high stress
situations with enhanced
uh interrogation yeah they call it bit
or TQ is Battlefield interrogation
techniques or TQ is tactical questioning
and in in like an initial
like if I first get a bad guy there
there are
more relaxed rules initially during the
initial time that we take this person in
to ask really relevant important
questions about saving and protecting
people's lives like specifically are
there any current operations that are
targeting
um you know Americans or their allies in
this region you know that line of
questioning
um and it's it's intense initially
back to the giving your address out on
Fox News
did uh just nothing came of it now
they're cowards
just flat out they're cowards you like
the Taliban just started reimposing
Sharia law in in Afghanistan you know
like girls like they're chopping off
people's hands yeah you know what's
happening in Iran that all the
protesters are getting murdered fourteen
thousand people are getting murdered is
that true yeah because so beautiful I
mean what what a courageous moment of
this young beautiful girl
took off her headscarf and she was
walking towards this paramilitary line
with her head scarf off in an active
Defiance and that was the last video
that anybody ever saw of her because
when they captured her then they beat
her tortured her to death
that sparked this initial
um I wish I could say a revolution but
it's not but it was like this big
protest in support of this first girl I
can't even pronounce her name
um that was tortured and murdered for
not wearing a headscarf so then
everybody started doing it and then what
did the Iranian government start doing
all the people that then were along with
this protest they're like cool we'll
just take you and you and you and you
and you and then just kill you
there's like 14 000 people there I don't
know the number but it's it's a crazy
absolutely unimaginable number and
they're like young people that just want
to live Jesus yeah
[ __ ] those guys that's gnarly yeah yeah
[ __ ] those guys and it's Cedar Crush
different [ __ ] but still [ __ ]
nonetheless yeah it's insane
um can I just like get along yeah tell
me about it yeah why can't we
[ __ ] there's always these outliers
you know is it like religion religion
plays but like religion does great
beautiful things yeah you know
um like the The Fringe ideas I'm in
Eastern Europe a lot right now and I was
you know in Afghanistan during the fall
of Afghanistan and the number of
religious
non-profits that were helping the
ukrainians helping orphans
um sending in humanitarian Aid to the
front lines Medical Aid you know the
Samaritan purse and then Afghanistan you
like the the Argo airlift and Glenn Beck
like I know so what did easy do to throw
darts at that guy spent
tens of millions of dollars helping
evacuate people out of Afghanistan that
we're going to be tortured by the
Taliban you know so like you got the
Mother Teresa on one end of the spectrum
you know and then you have priests
molesting kids yeah you know and like if
we're gonna throw that all under
underneath religion then that kind of
sucks but
you in in everything in human nature is
that spectrum of like greatness to
Absolute douchebags
yeah so I'm sure religion but also just
human humans yeah humans So when you say
that you're in Eastern Europe a lot my
God that's related to the Ukraine
conflict yeah yeah I go back like
five days ago
and and uh it went straight to honey
someone was saying that the Ukraine war
is like the longest running like
something like since World War II like
it's older than that
um the the people that built Moscow are
were from Kiev
right but the uh just this this one war
like it's uh did this conflict within
Vietnam go for like 20 something years
yeah I mean it but like I I don't know
if I forget what the metrics were but
like it's like we don't we don't
appreciate in America like the gravity
they
the extent of this conflict
ukrainians started training in
resistance
um a generation ago they started
teaching kids as young as eight years
old and we it was really easy for
propaganda wise the Russians to label
you know fascists and Nazis because of
the things that they saw in schools and
what we saw in schools was the
ukrainians training their young men how
to prepare to fight and a lot of those
things out of context look very like
authoritarian and very fascist and like
the worst enemy of a communist is a
fascist and the Ukrainian government was
training their young men to prepare for
exactly what happened which was a
Russian invasion across an
internationally recognized Sovereign
border and uh mass murder war crimes of
like absolute genocide they're trying to
erase a race
right now
and everything that we're seeing in the
news about how the Russian troops are
just like
[ __ ] and and you know like well like
their bombs weren't exploding and
they're abandoning all their stuff
they're like just losing retreating is
that the media spinning it a little bit
I mean they're a third world country
with nukes Russia is you know these
Russian troops
um were in bad Health you know bad
Dental Health bad Vision bad skin old
equipment you know seeing them firsthand
you're like good you're a soldier
especially like seeing American soldiers
to have like great equipment you know
and they're healthy and they take
physical tests you know and every year
they have dental and vision like all of
our soldiers are very like the vast
majority are very very healthy and then
you go over there like what the heck
what is wrong with you yeah
um but
it's a number game
the Russians can throw bodies at this
problem for forever and
um
it's also a way for them to get rid of
certain populations within Russia that
they want to kill
so that's where their draft comes in
yeah that's right they're called scripts
or the poor
um
ethnically groups that they don't care
about
so so they they'll
um Mike
design the draft to bring in ethnicities
that's right wow
that's not like a little bit like that's
100 correct wow yeah so that's uh
communism bro
it's bad it's it's not really really
really bad until you get to see what
it's really like and how bad it is where
there's somebody that's like all right
we're going to take 300 conscripts and
I'm going to hand pick the groups and
ethnicities that these people are coming
from
yeah wow now welcome to the party
and and uh
the like if we look at America on the
other side
um I think what one could argue that
there are certain changes that really
really need to be made
safe to say I'm pretty passionate about
this point I'm making right here because
change does need to be made and the
first change that I'd like to see made
is no more plastic polluting the
environment I mean for God's sakes
what's that plastic mountain in the
middle of the ocean the size of now
Africa for God's sakes we've got to
bring it into plastic and there's one
company leading the charge that company
is called liquid death I am an
ambassador for liquid death because I
believe in what they're doing I believe
in drinking a lot of water not soda and
I believe in their infinitely recyclable
tall boy cans which again it's just
water water but man does it look like a
beer and that is just a lot of fun man
I'm buddies with the CEO of liquid death
and he's tickled every time he hears
from a principal or a teacher hey your
child came into class drinking beer he's
like yeah dude don't be scared it's just
water and don't be scared of infinitely
recyclable aluminum because it's way
better for the world than plastic so
dude plus this mango chainsaw is my
favorite of the killer new flavors and
if you order from liquiddeath.com
Stevo you get free shipping on all of
your water and your merchandise and
their merchandise is equally hilarious
by the way plus water is pretty heavy so
they're gonna pay for free shipping for
you to order their killer water and be
saving the world for the love of God
dive onto this deal right now by going
to liquiddeath.com
Stevo for all this killer beer looking
water that's super good for you and
super good for the environment free
shipping on everything
liquiddeath.com
Stevo now let's talk about changing the
world some more but those changes flat
tax
[Music]
there's a lot of changes I think we
could agree need to be made but they'll
never be made because they're
inconvenient to the American you know
the American politician yeah nobody's
gonna vote for somebody who's gonna do
what needs to be done yeah what do you
want to see done like universal
healthcare
and how about like a universal basic
income maybe that wouldn't make sense
like uh who knows and and you know with
uh like all the the fossil for the
environment you know like it's it's
[ __ ] nuts it's [ __ ] nuts and if
we're gonna like not destroy the world
then we need to make some pretty radical
changes yeah I do think we need radical
changes but but the first radical change
is a society cultural one where people
can sit here and talk about things they
disagree with I'm fairly confident that
you and I would disagree on a lot of
topics and I'm pretty sure that we could
sit here like civilized people and talk
through them maybe we agree maybe we
don't agree but we would definitely find
a middle ground where if there was ever
going to be a compromise on either part
it would happen between two rational
people having a goddamn conversation
which evidently is impossible yeah well
I wouldn't assassinate your character if
I didn't do it you're a bigot whatever
about to say go on exactly yeah that's
what happened like immediately like no
man just take a breath yeah and listen
to this person and listening takes a
degree of empathy and sympathy for me to
like try to like look at the shoes and
see if I could walk a mile in your shoes
while you're talking
and then I'll then I'll respond but
that's gone I don't know it's coming
back is it pendulum doth swings back
okay I I just I can't open like what are
all the dumb truth social media or
parlor or Twitter or all of them are
just like crazy people yeah I think
social media is a really big problem too
for sure it doesn't incentivize people
to like talk negatively well yeah I mean
dude like you ever you ever have
somebody talk [ __ ] on like one of your
and then you see that person in real
life is that a rapping to you it's
happened one time because I actually
don't read any of my comments I was on
Lance Armstrong uh another Texan great
man you should do a podcast with him
he's brilliant super successful
entrepreneur and invest stir in addition
to like being one of the greatest
athletes in our time
um and I was on hit podcast and
obviously I'm a freedom forward person
which would include guns and uh Lance
has never shot a gun before and he's
like he and his audience are on the
opposite end of the spectrum when it
comes to like Second Amendment stuff and
like I love all of them like I'm a
constitutionalist totally and
in our conversation I
compromised language and said you know
he's like are you for any forms of of
gun control and I was like well all gun
laws are a form of gun control and there
are good gun laws so could gun could gun
control be a solution absolutely that
one sentence of Tim Kennedy saying that
gun control is a solution every single
conservative on the planet was like Tim
Kennedy's a Redcoat you know he's a fud
he's a complete Trader you know I was
like it was just agreeing with somebody
that doesn't speak the same language as
me to like and gun laws are a form of
gun control and that we have great gun
laws if you have a restraining order you
can't go buy a gun you know if you're a
felon you can't go go buy a gun if
you're addicted to some pretty nasty
drugs you can't go buy a gun if you've
been dishonorably discharged you can't
go buy a gun if you've been uh in a
psychiatric ward in the last five years
or
yeah I just bought a lever action and I
oh cool I ended up buying a bunch of I
like lever action yeah they're fun
Winchester and um 4570 those are heavy
to shoot but uh yeah the the amount of
questions they ask you but is that state
by state do they that's Federal so so
those same questions that I get asked in
California the same everywhere that's
right the blankets they haven't across
the yeah yeah what percentage of
is it some crazy percentage of um
like gun deaths are people with their
own gun oh it's almost everyone and then
and then the remaining little bits are
um
bad guys using guns against other bad
guys right like the the number of of gun
deaths against like you know
um like the gun being used the way it
was yeah it's so rare I mean like a
diamond
um it's wild to finish that
Lance Armstrong story
a newspaper journalist wrote this big
thing about how as a traitor and then
posted a whole bunch of stuff online and
then I saw him in person it was like oh
you know Mr Kennedy I was just I was
like pause with the Mr Kennedy thing you
know you called me a traitor you know
I've been in the military for 18 years
you know like and and now you're already
like Rick and dream and scooching back
like I can pull your article out here
you literally called me a traitor to
this country and uh you know you want to
talk about these no you know like I
think it was just a misunderstand I was
like it wasn't you wrote it in black and
white and he just could not be more of a
coward and that's how they all are yeah
you know I mean that's crazy yeah that's
the that's the lot we got introduced to
you as uh when Rogan's American as [ __ ]
yeah
yeah poor Joe yeah he says a American
ass [ __ ] meet Tim Kennedy he's American
as [ __ ] yeah
I'm getting I'm loving Joe and Joe more
being in Texas and I can see that yeah
he's uh yeah he's good he's good he's
getting what it was I don't know if you
know that Joe being in Texas changes Joe
in any way even slightly
um I think Joe is just very much Joe
yeah and uh it did how great for you
how often you guys meet up not often
enough that guy is so flying all over
the world whether it's UFC or another
show
um I
yeah do you miss fighting not a bit not
a bit no you were fighting at 185 yeah
why he'd buy Welch away and middleweight
and light heavyweight that's right
yeah yeah wow for all of your brain
damage it's it's impressive yeah
there's a clip going on around you on
Tick Tock where you're like backstage is
it yoel Romero you're standing you're
ready to go or yep yeah the uh it was a
title elimination fight Michael bisbing
was the champion and I just beat the
brakes off of him and you're well Joel
Romero and myself were the two clear
contenders for who's gonna fight for the
next championship and
um we fought each other I knocked him
out in the end of the second round and
then
the bell rings and he doesn't answer the
bell and
um and it's real clear rules to the
athletic commission you have 10 seconds
to answer the Bell if you don't it's a
forfeit so 10 seconds goes by 15 seconds
20 seconds 30 and he's just not coming
out and uh so like I start celebrating
mouthpieces out I'm pointing at Danny
White you know like hey you're paying me
and like give me my title fight a point
at my wife like wear those red panties
you know like it's gonna be a great
night you know just totally celebrating
and um
and
for whatever reason the the ref lets the
fight then commence
um you know a minute and 40 something
seconds later and I get just obliterated
and all the adrenaline was out of here
yeah on partying mode Jesus he the whole
time you know he's he's sitting there on
the stool just dead focused on me trying
to get back in the fight and the whole
time I'm just leaving the fight and uh
so that after
UL comes up and starts apologizing to me
in the back and I was like you know the
rules you know that you cheated you know
don't come back here and and try to
placate another coward and uh like you
know exactly what you did yeah and uh
it's fine you cheated and you got away
with it but don't come back here and
talk to me about it right that's that
was that video man he's like you just
saw an American and
he's uh he is an American he's Cuban
yeah no you've seen that to him okay
um it was a joke that didn't hit well
did you uh
do you watch the UFC all the time no no
no I have a few teammates and friends
that still fight but um as you know
because I've been retired now three
years four years
um fewer and fewer of my former
teammates or friends are still fighting
Cowboy just retired you know yeah Jon
Jones is coming back you know he's a
former teammate he's going to be Jackson
wink yeah he's going to be moving up to
heavyweight so I can all watch him fight
yeah but uh like if I don't watch to
fight so you trained in Albuquerque yeah
you're from L.A I'm from Central
California
that's right yeah and Chuck Liddell got
you into fighting he did yeah he he
showed up and and just mopped the floor
with my face and and I was the big fish
in a little Pond and then
a very talented fish came in here and
just humiliated this little fish and I
was like I don't know what you're doing
but I want to go do it and that was with
John hackelman and Glover takashara and
Gan McGee and Cruz it was just like the
who's who of fighting in the day we're
all like there in San Luis Obispo crazy
that Glover to share is still going so
cool yeah he's about to fight for the
title again he's 43 44. [ __ ] yeah yeah
what makes him different because he's
like crushing it right now yeah he had a
long spell in the middle of his career
where he didn't fight because he
couldn't he had a permit problem
so he will say he's a late bloomer but
even though he started training very
young I trained with him with his purple
belt and uh but while he is waiting for
visas it was like a five six year time
period where his body just didn't get
that damage or he was just waiting
yeah so yeah yeah stylistically also
he's
he's now taking damage but for the you
know the past
eight years he was a hard person to hurt
you know he wouldn't stand in the pocket
because people didn't want to stand in
the pocket because he hit so hard and
then you know he's a Grappler heavy guy
so he just he didn't get a lot of damage
which which adds to the longevity of a
career
you know a guy that
that uh will just you know go toe-to-toe
and bang short careers
yeah right I was there in the Apex and
Glover against Thiago Santos whoa yeah
that he was he was hurt and came back
and
man I just love it man I'm I'm like I I
watch all of it yeah the uh I wanted to
watch this last fight
but uh I was overseas so I missed it
yeah
so I said you're you're
you took the picture with uh were they
deer and you're in your truck yeah and
uh like like that was you took it and
just texted it to me like that was that
moment yep that was it just like they're
like yeah just finished gotta that's
that's gonna be one of those is gonna be
about
300 pounds of meat wow and that'll feed
you for like two weeks no I'm not
kidding yeah family uh for like a year
for a family of four yeah
yeah every bit of a year how much does
that deer cost you to to shoot and
fillet up so here's wild it's on this
big huge Ranch down in Southwest Texas
and
um this Ranch
has cattle on it and the cattle because
it's dry each cattle you you calculate
how many acres per head of cattle do you
need to have for that cattle to have
enough food but then you have a big huge
animal like an elk that comes in and
eats the grass you have less grass well
the elk also have huge horns when they
go to get into the water trough it
breaks the water trough when they go to
hop a fence which they can do because
they're not a cow they break the fence
and the cows can get out so the ranch
the ranchers don't want these elk on
their property because it's not good for
them to have cattle so but there's a lot
of us that think that's the most
delicious meat on the planet and we love
elk
um so I pay the Rancher access to his
property there's no public land really
in Texas like Colorado or Idaho or you
know there's I'm not asking the
government permission to go on I'm
asking a private Ranch owner if it's
okay for me to go into his property to
shoot something and then I pay the ranch
or whatever I shot
so if you're gonna shoot like
a cow you know you have to a female elk
you have to make sure that you know it
doesn't have a calf with it like it's
not raising a little one right if I'm
gonna shoot a a coal which is like a
genetic male that's not good so we want
like nice normal healthy herds but maybe
this one has like a spike for its for
its horn and then like a regular antler
over here but elk fight so when he goes
to fight another elk he's gonna stab him
right and so like we want to get rid of
that because that's a bad Gene that is
bad for the genetics of or maybe they
have like a busted leg or like a disease
that's a coal animal and each of those
things are different prices and then a
trophy even that's a bad word for you me
paying that Rancher to shoot a big
beautiful one that we have like
genetically shaped because we've gotten
rid of the bad ones so we've gotten
really bad little girls and we've gotten
rid of like the busted up dudes now
we're gonna have a big beautiful Oak I'm
gonna pay that Rancher the most for the
this big beautiful elk which would call
a trophy and and I'm just paying the
Rancher one access and then two for the
animal off of his property
so in that case you're gonna eat
everything right you're gonna eat the
trophy so it's not like you eat the
heart and just paint the blood on your
face like a Savage so the problem
um I'm a real
I love my father and I'm gonna try out
you're if when you're born in the late
70s 74. you are my man so like growing
up in the 80s
um different thing uh if I had wounded
an animal
with my dad it would be a bad day
um so when I shoot an animal now I
double punch lungs and and pretty much
their heart explodes because the bullet
goes like it goes through this right
here it comes out here so they have no
lungs they have no heart so they're just
like walking eating grass like looking
over at the other female elk like hey
what's up and then there then it's
Darkness it's just like it's that so
like was that a bee sting and then
they're dead so there's no like ritual
you do like you don't say a prayer
before you shoot it or anything like
that I appreciate them like uh I had my
son my seven-year-old son with me and
when we walked up you know like
it's still hot you know you put your
hand on it you know and it's like man
thank you for your life I value you you
know and you know it's like I appreciate
its life and um he's gonna give
nutrients to my family and his death
it's great yeah but I'm like on my knees
like you know
[ __ ] Gomer Pyle yeah
um with
your relation to law enforcement like
how like uh you had nothing to do with
with cops you're military and that's no
I have a lot to do with cops okay yeah
you train them wait I do train them and
my my brother and my dad are lifetime
law enforcement
um and in some of the areas that I work
I work alongside of law enforcement
or counter human trafficking you know
counter drug
um here in Texas we've had a real
problem with the border right and uh and
that there's a military response there
is a law enforcement response there's
even a civilian humanitarian because I
mean it is a humanitarian crisis when
you're down the Border
so there's a lot of layers of is it
scary
how all right
a few people want to be cops now yeah
it's bad like how like many people are
ceasing to be cops this is a byproduct
of society though right right like we've
demonized them right uh We've called
them murderers and
um and I will be the first when when
because that person is in a position of
authority they have to be held at a
higher standard right like I'm going to
expect that person to be more moral to
be more ethical to have more Integrity
right and when they don't we we Hammer
them because the like everybody needs to
know that that person in that position
of authority is there to protect and
serve the community that is there that
is you know that is theirs
and um but what has happened of late is
we have with a very broad brush painted
all of them as criminals you know like
all of them are the guy with the knee on
the back of George Floyd you know all of
them are the racist all of them are the
blah insert all of them are the bigot
and now we don't have enough of them and
now crime is out of control
it's gnarly like with the now like
carjackings are so the norm yeah
like home invasion
in where was it Chicago you got like
[ __ ] gun battles going on they're
just like oh it was mutual combat yeah
we're in America yeah we're like calling
mutual combat in a in a suburb of
Chicago right
it's a friendly fire yeah it
it was uh it was a fair fight it was a
clean fight
there's a gun fight but whatever yeah
what the heck I mean like it's getting
really scary and uh I'm personally very
uncomfortable with the way that police
have been demonized yeah
um
when they do something wrong
I have to hold them to the standard
but we also have to recognize that these
outliers these these rare instances are
just that rare instances when you look
at law enforcement as a whole they're
incredible servants selfless servants
that are like they're not there for a
paycheck because they don't make enough
money right they care about that there's
something in them that they want to
protect their communities you know like
heaven forbid the Valdez shooting thing
ever happens again but if it does
those people that were like fighting to
get in those doors to go to get those
kids like the the border patrol officers
that climbed through Windows that's the
heart of a protector yeah you know
and God bless them yeah yeah well is
that what's going to happen then it's
like well we don't have enough military
we don't have enough cops let's send the
military in here well we've been out
there who did such a good job let's send
more yeah and more but there's this
thing in the Constitution that prohibits
directly American soldiers operating
within the American Border
so you have Texas National you have a
National Guard which are State assets
which are not federal soldiers so in the
instances that you've seen soldiers like
currently on the Texas border those are
Texas National Guardsmen that work for
the state there's so you wouldn't have
the Army come in no
Navy or no Coast Guard no never
nope not unless you have Ships coming up
you know yeah
from North Korea yeah are we seeing in
the military any similar dynamic as
we're seeing with uh police
yeah that there's not enough that people
don't want to do it yeah
so uh
yeah it's like
are other countries doing that too is it
like that yeah like everybody doesn't
want to join the military in Russia and
well I guess you don't have a choice
yeah Russia and China North Korea you
can't take into the pool of oh you're 18
sick
you're poor awesome cool yeah the uh the
benefits that you get for joining the
military are very real right education
amazing three Hots in the cot yeah no
that's jail
it's not jail we're talking about
positive things here yeah my girls are
going to college for free because I went
to war and I got the Montgomery GI bill
um so wow yeah my daughters are going to
college for free they get paid like a
salary to go to school and all their
tuition is paid for
um they paid off my
um so like when I joined I whatever
school debt I had they paid off you know
like you talk about real student loan
repayment program how about you go do
some goddamn work for it like I [ __ ]
did because I went and fought for my
country like you can go do that anybody
could do that that's available for
anybody so if I had like 90 000 in call
college debt go join the military
they'll pay it off fixed [ __ ] you know
and you get to do something rad yeah
I have no idea how many countries I've
been to in the military yeah you know
like amazing Dental look at these teeth
yeah when uh I I have a beautiful family
and I'm so proud of uh my co-pay
for my last daughter to be born was like
three dollars
yeah in a [ __ ] elk tenderloin
I did have a rad like battle ax put over
her crib that my wife took down it's now
in my office she wouldn't let me hang it
over her crib it was right before you
gave out your address yeah
poor woman
she's amazing how long you been married
18 years wow yeah
it's crazy yeah almost I'm rounding up
you don't you don't want to get that
wrong
all right well yeah we have to go to the
airport we should go to the airport wait
I want you guys to stay in Texas we'll
come back out okay this weekend
um I'm teaching a precision rifle course
it's like teaching people how to shoot
things really really far away how many
businesses do you own
uh uh like me Foley eight but I own like
a bunch of little bits of other
companies too on it your own part about
it no no no no no no liver Relentless
which is the supplement line a
competitor of on it okay
um the uh I worked for on it and
marketed for Onyx and it was a sponsored
athlete when I was fighting for on it
right still love on it like great stuff
great people
um but when they they got bought and
right
um like the
OG crew of the founders like got
replaced like which always happens peace
with your eight businesses and your
pieces of other businesses like you're
just straight killing it yeah life is so
good life is like really real I have I
get to have
like
like a positive impact to my community
to my tribe that we're talking about you
know like being able to my neighbors are
going to get coolers full of elk and
bison for example so I said yeah I want
to go when I said the in the photo you
sent dear but deer is not elk deer is
not elk it was elk deer is fine we are
we're in the middle of rifle deer season
right now but um those are it would take
it would take
10 to 12 Deer to equal the amount of
meat that came off of my one elk all
right yeah it's kind of crazy so
family's great business is great killing
it and uh military's great yeah it's um
you know like I enlisted under Bush and
uh went to war
two times with bush
um then
to President Obama and then to president
Trump and to President Biden so like
I've worked for a variety of different
administrations and uh there's highs and
lows in all of it but like the the thing
that I love the most is the work that we
do and I think it's it's something that
is very rarely talked about is how much
good the the American Military does
overseas
[Music]
um
humanitarian in Ukraine building schools
in Africa you know building wells in
Africa right the uh and not because
there's some strategic necessity or that
we need to be the policers or anything
or even that we own owe anyone anything
it's just like we're Americans and we
can do cool things for people because
we're the greatest country that's ever
existed so if you're in a bad way well
like
run up beaches and climb Cliffs and
maybe drop a nuclear bomb on you if
you're an [ __ ]
um but you know like if you need help
we'll be there we'll pay for your
college yeah yeah that's cool it is
correct dude that's a I I didn't realize
that and maybe a lot of people listening
my student the student loan repayment
program
like that so you enlist you have to you
know get through basic training finish
your AIT get to your unit get healthy
you got to do push-ups and sit-ups and
all of a sudden your shit's paid for
check three blocks cool your school's
paid for you know and then like they pay
it off in phases of of how long you're
in so like if you're in for four years
you actually have to at the end of your
four years they're like they'll write
that last check it's pretty cool
some people go through their whole life
without even paying their college off I
don't understand that one why would like
and they don't even finish yeah
we could talk about that for years
but yeah do something that makes you
happy yeah first and foremost yeah we're
really excited about seeing you we came
out to Austin we're like dude let's hit
up Tim Kennedy I haven't slept yet so I
literally I got back from Eastern Europe
and then I went to hunt and I hunted
straight for three days you texted me as
I was driving back from Southwest Texas
40 50 miles from Mexico and um if you
can see in my face like I am going to go
to sleep right now you look great and
I'm gonna sleep for a while I think you
look great I'm super strict you're
killing it I love seeing you yeah I love
seeing you anything I can ever do for
you guys you call me dad you're the best
man apocalypse happens come here yeah oh
yeah facial recognition software at your
house just remember us you have that
dude was that fascinating or what man I
love that guy and I love we man too
we've got this pro model skateboard with
both of us on it and we're doing battle
we're just balls deep in trying to
figure out who can come up with the most
awesome skateboarding footage and dude I
came up with this idea I was like
what's a silly relatable thing and I
thought about Skip roping I'm like what
if I like have a skip rope but I'm
riding a skateboard and I'm ollieing
through the skip rope I didn't even know
if it was possible I had no clue and
honestly I fell pretty hard a couple
times trying it but dude I ended up
like five Skipper up jumps in a row it
was like Ollie rope
I you know what Paul if I can check it
on here man